[Music]
you've done some work on nature and the
pious nature yeah years ago yes would
you be able to explain what the how you
can see neat tuner pious work in a pious
way yeah oh well that's that is quite
interesting so neat nature so Nietzsche
came from a very long line of clergy his
dad was worn his you know grandfathers
and going back there was loads of them
his dad died when he was quite young and
he was brought up by his mum and sisters
in a you know in a very sort of pie see
he won Nietzsche won the University
preaching prize you know this is and
then all of that and it I mean when he
sort of became an atheist and a
campaigning atheist the really
interesting thing about his atheism was
that it it there was a sort of piety
about it there was a sort of the world
depends on this almost almost your
salvation depends on this I mean
obviously in a secular way but you know
that the question of God became a
question of real importance Tim and and
in fact for me that was one of the
things that was really instrumental in
my conversion to Christianity so I went
to university fairly straightforward
atheist and Nietzsche and others
Kierkegaard and a few others but they
raised the question of God in such a way
that I thought I had to give it an
answer it would suddenly this was an
important I suddenly realised why the
question was important whereas before I
didn't even think the question was
important that's what of atheist that's
the real atheism by the way indifference
is the real that's the real atheism the
Dawkins type of atheism that's that's
not it that's fine that's always it
that's a tiny flip away from
Christianity but indifference that's
that that's the thing that Christians
should be most afraid of and Nietzsche
and it was absolutely not indifferent
you know this is he raised the question
of God in such a way that I knew
something really serious depended upon
how I answered it
so that was the beginnings of my sort of
struggle with Christianity and for years
and people you say about me no chance
got this weird hobby you know Java is
weird hobby he's like he's interested in
religion you know and he reads all that
stuff on the side and I did and it was a
for a long time it was a sort of quite
an academic not that Nietzsche is a sort
of academic II writer per se you know
he's too passionate for that but for a
while it was that for me and then
somehow I realized that I wasn't on the
outside looking in but I was on the
inside looking out and it had shaped my
world and I knew that that's what I had
to do and I still feel I still feel the
same way about it as I did when I I
guess conversion is them would and what
was it about those thinkers that made
you realize the importance of it was it
like their passion or the passion is
arguments more passion ism is an aspect
of it but it was also a way of seeing
the world and and and whereas before I'd
have looked at the world and the
question of God was not raised by the
world I looked at after reading all that
sort of stuff I'd look at the sort of
you know this beautiful scene and I
would go there's something about is this
which is asking me a question which I'd
never before and fun enough it's the
persistence of the question that in the
end the end makes you see the world
differently you know it's not very very
few people that argued into faith and in
fact that's why much to atheists
frustration that's why people can't be
argued out of it either you know you
don't get argued in out of something
you've never argued into you know so
it's more like falling in love you know
and you can fall out of love and so
there is a process but but but it isn't
quite so susceptible to rational
argument as many atheists presume so
they're quite frustrated they can't
they've won the
argument but why is nothing happened
with the person they think they won the
argument with and that's sort of because
they're missing what it is that's
charging the Christian vision and is
that not also he said that new atheism
isn't atheism it's not indifference are
they also tackling with looking at the
world and yes it's just no I mean new a
new atheism is a very interesting
phenomena I mean I have all sorts of
problems with it but in one way much
much more like Christianity than either
side would feel comfortable with
actually you know that as I said
indifference is is the thing that is the
real killer but but I mean lots of new
atheists passionately engaged with the
sort of beauty of the world with with
the nature of justice with the nature of
what is right with the nature of the
meaning of life the universe and
everything and all that sort of stuff
I I to my taste in argumentative terms
it's more flat-footed than it used to be
I mean I think you know Nietzsche's
Nietzsche hated Christianity he didn't
just think it was wrong he thought it
was wicked and that there was a sort of
something that and he also realized
Nietzsche did and I think that New
Atheists don't get this
Nietzsche realize that the most
important question is not the question
about whether God exists then the most
important question is sort of the
question of personal salvation is that
how do I fit into this sort of lichen
and how is this broken person somehow or
the languages saved you know now that
the idea that religion begins with the
question of salvation something that
Luther for instance would be would would
be terribly important to and and
Nietzsche was a sore Lutheran minister
so Nietzsche asked the question of
salvation and answered it by your saved
by being an atheist
okay that's sort of it
the New Atheists not interested in that
question they really only want to know
whether there is a thing up there called
God or is there not a thing up there
cook on they think that's the nature of
the argument and I'm less interested in
that question and people think I should
be actually you know that's not that's
not the thing that keeps me awake at
night
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you